[Music]
somebody asked for the cigars
we had talked long and the conversation
was beginning to languish
the tobacco smoke had got into the heavy
curtains the wine had got into those
brains which were liable to become heavy
and it was already perfectly evident
that unless somebody did something
to rouse our oppressed spirits the
meeting would soon come to its natural
conclusion
and we the guests would speedily go home
to bed
and most certainly to sleep no one had
said anything very remarkable
it may be that no one had anything very
remarkable to say
jones had given us every particular of
his last hunting adventure in yorkshire
mr tomkins of boston had explained at
elaborate length those working
principles
by the dew and careful maintenance of
which the atchison topeka and santa fe
railroad
not only extended its territory
increased its departmental influence
and transported livestock without
starving them to death before the day of
actual delivery
but also had for years succeeded in
deceiving those passengers who bought
its tickets
into the fallacious belief that the
corporation of forsed
was really able to transport human life
without destroying it
senior tombola had endeavored to
persuade us by
arguments which we took no trouble to
oppose that the unity of his country
in no way resembled the average modern
torpedo
carefully planned constructed with all
the skill of the greatest
european arsenals but when constructed
destined to be directed by feeble hands
into a region where it must undoubtedly
explode
unseen unfeared and unheard into the
illimitable wastes of political chaos
it is unnecessary to go into further
details
the conversation had assumed proportions
which would have bored prometheus on his
rock
which would have driven tantalus to
distraction and which would have
impelled ixian to seek relaxation
in the simple but instructive dialogues
of hair olendorf
rather than submit to the greater evil
of listening to our talk
we had sat at the table for hours we
were bored
we were tired and nobody showed signs of
moving
somebody called for cigars we all
instinctively looked towards the speaker
brisbane was a man of five and thirty
years of age
and remarkable for those gifts which
chiefly attract the attention of men
he was a strong man the external
proportions of his figure presented
nothing extraordinary to the common eye
though his size was above the average he
was a little over
six feet in height and moderately broad
in the shoulder
he did not appear to be stout but on the
other hand he was certainly not thin
his small head was supported by a strong
insinue neck
his broad muscular hands appeared to
possess a peculiar skill in breaking
walnuts
without the assistance of the ordinary
cracker and seeing him in profile
one could not help remarking the
extraordinary breadth of his sleeves
and the unusual thickness of his chest
he was one of those men who were
commonly spoken of among men as
deceptive
that is to say that though he looked
exceedingly strong
he was in reality very much stronger
than he looked
of his features i need say little his
head is small
his hair is thin his eyes are blue
his nose is large he has a small
mustache
and a square jaw everybody knows
brisbane
and when he asked for a cigar everybody
looked at him
it is a very singular thing said
brisbane
everybody stopped talking brisbane's
voice was not loud
but possessed a peculiar quality of
penetrating general conversation
and cutting it like a knife everybody
listened
brisbane perceiving that he had
attracted their general attention
lit his cigar with great equanimity
it is very singular he continued that
thing about
ghosts people are always asking whether
anybody has seen a ghost
i have bosh what you
you don't mean to say so brisbane well
for a man of his intelligence
a chorus of exclamations greeted
brisbane's remarkable statement
everybody called for cigars and stubbs
the butler
suddenly appeared from the depths of
nowhere with a fresh bottle of dry
champagne the situation was saved
brisbane was going to tell a story
i am an old sailor said brisbane and as
i have to cross the atlantic pretty
often
i have my favorites most men have their
favorites
i have seen a man wait in a broadway bar
for three quarters of an hour
for a particular car which he liked i
believe the bar keeper made at least one
third of his living
by that man's preference i have a habit
of waiting for certain ships when i am
obliged to cross that duck pond
it may be a prejudice but i was never
cheated out of a good passage
but once in my life i remember it very
well
it was a warm morning in june and the
custom house officials
who were hanging about waiting for a
steamer already on her way up from the
quarantine
presented a peculiarly hazy and
thoughtful appearance
i had not much luggage i never have
i mingled with the crowd of passengers
porters and officious individuals in
blue coats and brass buttons
who seem to spring up like mushrooms
from the deck of a moored steamer
to obtrude their unnecessary services
upon the independent passenger
i have often noticed with a certain
interest the spontaneous evolution of
these fellows
they are not there when you arrive five
minutes after the pilot has called go
ahead
they or at least their blue coats and
brass buttons
had disappeared from deck and gangway as
completely as though they had been
consigned to that locker
which tradition unanimously ascribes to
davy jones
but at the moment of starting they are
there clean shaved
blue coated and ravenous for fees
i hastened on board the kamchatka was
one of my favorite ships
i say was because she emphatically no
longer is
i cannot conceive of any inducement
which can entice me to make another
voyage in her
yes i know what you're going to say she
is uncommonly clean in the run aft
she has enough bluffing off in the bows
to keep her dry
and the lower births are most of them
double she has a lot of advantages
but i won't cross in her again excuse
the digression
i got on board i hailed a steward whose
red nose and redder whiskers were
equally familiar to me
105 lower birth said i
in the business-like tone peculiar to
men who think no more of crossing the
atlantic
than taking a whiskey cocktail at
downtown del monaco's
the steward took my portmanteau great
coat and rug
i shall never forget the expression of
his face
not that he turned pale it is maintained
by the most eminent divines that even
miracles cannot change the course of
nature
i have no hesitation in saying that he
did not turn pale
but from his expression i judge that he
was either about to shed tears
to sneeze or to drop my portmanteau
as the latter contained two bottles of
particularly fine old sherry
presented to me for my voyage by my old
sniggins and van pickens
i felt extremely nervous but the steward
did none of these things
well i'm damned said he in a low voice
and led the way i supposed my hermes
as he led me to the lower regions had
had a little grog
but i said nothing and followed him 105
was on the port side
well aft there was nothing remarkable
about the stateroom
the lower birth like most of those upon
the kamjaka
was double there was plenty of room
there was the usual washing apparatus
calculated to convey an idea of luxury
to the mind of a north american indian
there were the usual inefficient racks
of brown wood
in which it is more easy to hang a
large-sized umbrella than the common
toothbrush of commerce
upon the uninviting mattresses were
carefully folded together those blankets
which a great modern humorist has aptly
compared to cold
buckwheat cakes the question of towels
was left entirely to the imagination
the glass decanters were filled with a
transparent liquid
faintly tinged with brown but from which
an odor less faint
but not more pleasing ascended to the
nostrils
like a far-off seasick reminiscence of
oily machinery
sad colored curtains half-closed the
upper birth
the hazy june daylight shed a faint
illumination upon the desolate little
scene
ugh how i hate that stateroom
the steward deposited my traps and
looked at me as though he wanted to get
away
probably in search of more passengers
and more fees
it is always a good plan to start in
favor with these functionaries
and i accordingly gave him certain coins
there and then
i'll try and make you as comfortable as
i can he remarked
as he put the coins in his pocket
nevertheless there was a doubtful
intonation in his voice which surprised
me
possibly his scale of fees had gone up
and he was not satisfied
but on the whole i was inclined to think
that as he himself would have expressed
it
he was the better for a glass i was
wrong however
and did the man injustice
nothing especially worthy of mention
occurred during that day
we left the pier punctually and it was
very pleasant to be fairly underway
for the weather was warm and sultry and
the motion of the steamer produced a
refreshing breeze
everybody knows what the first day at
sea is like
people pace the decks and stare at each
other and occasionally meet
acquaintances
whom they did not know to be on board
there is the usual uncertainty as to
whether the food will be good
bad or indifferent until the first two
meals have put the matter beyond a doubt
there is the usual uncertainty about the
weather until the ship is fairly off
fire island
the tables are crowded at first and then
suddenly thinned
pale faced people spring from their
seats and precipitate themselves towards
the door
and each old sailor breathes more freely
as his seasick neighbor rushes from his
side
leaving him plenty of elbow room and an
unlimited command over the mustard
one passage across the atlantic is very
much like another
and we who cross very often do not make
the voyage for the sake of novelty
whales and icebergs are indeed always
objects of interest
but after all one whale is very much
like another whale
and one rarely sees an iceberg at close
quarters
to the majority of us the most
delightful moment of the day on board an
ocean steamer
is when we have taken our last turn on
deck have smoked our last cigar
and having succeeded in tiring ourselves
feel at liberty to turn in with a clear
conscience
on that first night of the voyage i felt
particularly lazy
and went to bed in 105 rather earlier
than i usually do
as i turned in i was amazed to see that
i was to have a companion
[Music]
a portmanteau very like my own lay in
the opposite corner
and in the upper berth had ben deposited
a neatly folded rug
with a stick and umbrella i had hoped to
be alone
and i was disappointed but i wondered
who my roommate was to be
and i determined to have a look at him
before i had been long in bed he entered
he was as far as i could see a very tall
man
very thin very pale with sandy hair and
whiskers
and colorless gray eyes he had about him
i thought
an air of rather dubious fashion the
sort of man you might see in wall street
without being able precisely to say what
he was doing there
the sort of man who frequents the cafe
on glaze
who always seems to be alone and who
drinks champagne
you might meet him on a race course but
he would never appear to be doing
anything there either
a little overdressed a little odd
there are three or four of his kind on
every ocean steamer
i made up my mind that i did not care to
make his acquaintance
and i went to sleep saying to myself
that i would study his habits
in order to avoid him if he rose early
i would rise late if he went to bed late
i would go to bed early
i did not care to know him if you once
know people of that kind they are always
turning up
poor fellow i need not have taken the
trouble to come to so many decisions
about him
for i never saw him again after that
first night in 105
i was sleeping soundly when i was
suddenly waked by a loud noise
to judge from the sound my roommate must
have sprung up with a single leap from
the upper berth to the floor
i heard him fumbling with the latch and
bolt of the door which opened almost
immediately
and then i heard his footsteps as he ran
at full speed down the passage
leaving the door open behind him the
ship was rolling a little
and i expected to hear him stumble or
fall but he ran as though he were
running for his life
the door swung on its hinges with the
motion of the vessel
and the sound annoyed me i got up and
shut it
and groped my way back to my birth in
the darkness
i went to sleep again but i have no idea
how long i slept
when i awoke it was still quite dark but
i felt a disagreeable sensation of cold
and it seemed to me that the air was
damp
you know the peculiar smell of a cabin
which has been wet with seawater
i covered myself up as well as i could
and dozed off again
framing complaints to be made the next
day and selecting the most powerful
epithets in the language
i could hear my roommate turn over in
the upper birth
he had probably returned while i was
asleep
once i thought i heard him groan and i
argued that he was seasick
that is particularly unpleasant when one
is below
nevertheless i dozed off and slept till
early daylight
the ship was rolling heavily much more
than on the previous evening
and the gray light which came in through
the porthole changed intent with every
movement
according as the angle of the vessel's
side turned the glass
seawards or skywards it was very cold
unaccountably so for the month of june i
turned my head and looked at the
porthole
and saw to my surprise that it was wide
open and hooked back
i believe i swore audibly then i got up
and shut it
as i turned back i glanced at the upper
berth
the curtains were drawn close together
my companion had probably felt cold as
well as i
it struck me that i had slept enough the
stateroom was uncomfortable
though strange to say i could not smell
the dampness which had annoyed me in the
night
my roommate was still asleep excellent
opportunity for avoiding him
so i dressed at once and went on deck
the day was warm and cloudy with an oily
smell on the water
it was seven o'clock as i came out much
later than i had imagined
i came across the doctor who was taking
his first sniff of the morning air
he was a young man from the west of
ireland a tremendous fellow with black
hair and blue eyes
already inclined to be stout he had a
happy-go-lucky healthy look about him
which was rather attractive
fine morning i remarked by way of
introduction
well said he eyeing me with an air of
ready interest
it's a fine morning and it's not a fine
morning i don't think it's much of a
morning
well no it is not so very fine said i
it's just what i call fugly weather
replied the doctor
it was very cold last night i thought i
remarked
however when i looked about i found that
the porthole was wide open
i had not noticed it when i went to bed
and the stateroom was damp too
damp said he whereabouts are you
105 to my surprise the doctor started
visibly
and stared at me what's the matter i
asked
oh nothing he answered only everybody
has complained of that stateroom for the
last three trips
i shall complain too i said it has
certainly not been properly aired
it is a shame i don't believe it can be
helped
answered the doctor i believe there is
something
well it's not my business to frighten
passengers
you need not be afraid of frightening me
i replied
i can stand any amount of damp if i
should get a bad cold i will come to you
i offered the doctor a cigar which he
took and examined very critically
it is not so much the damp he remarked
however
i dare say you will get on very well
have you a roommate
yes a deuce of a fellow who bolts out in
the middle of the night and leaves the
door open
again the doctor glanced curiously at me
then he lit the cigar and looked grave
did he come back he asked presently
yes i was asleep but i woke up and heard
him moving
then i felt cold and went to sleep again
this morning i found the porthole open
look here said the doctor quietly
i don't care much for this ship i don't
care a wrap for her reputation
i tell you what i will do i have a
good-sized place up here
i will share it with you though i don't
know you from adam
i was very much surprised at the
proposition i could not imagine why he
should take such a sudden interest in my
welfare
however his manner as he spoke of the
ship was peculiar
you were very good doctor i said but
really
i believe even now the cabin should be
aired or cleaned out or something
why do you not care for the ship we are
not superstitious in our profession sir
replied the doctor but the sea makes
people so
i don't want to prejudice you and i
don't want to frighten you
but if you will take my advice you will
move in here
i would as soon see you overboard he
added earnestly
as know that you or any other man was to
sleep in 105.
good gracious why i asked
just because on the last three trips the
people who have slept there
actually have gone overboard he answered
gravely
the intelligence was startling and
exceedingly unpleasant i confess
i looked hard at the doctor to see
whether he was making a game of me
but he looked perfectly serious i
thanked him warmly for his offer
but told him i intended to be the
exception to the rule by which everyone
who slept in that particular stateroom
went overboard
he did not say much but looked as grave
as ever
and hinted that before we got across i
should probably reconsider his proposal
in the course of time we went to
breakfast at which only an
inconsiderable number of passengers
assembled
i noticed that one or two of the
officers who breakfasted with us
looked grave after breakfast i went into
my stateroom in order to get a book
the curtains of the upper birth were
still closely drawn
not a word was to be heard my roommate
was probably still asleep
as i came out i met the steward whose
business it was to look after me
he whispered that the captain wanted to
see me and then scuttled away down the
passage
as if very anxious to avoid any
questions
i went toward the captain's cabin and
found him waiting for me
sir said he i want to ask a favor of you
i answered that i would do anything to
oblige him
your roommate has disappeared he said
he is known to have turned in early last
night did you notice anything
extraordinary in his manner
the question coming as it did in exact
confirmation of the fears the doctor had
expressed half an hour earlier
staggered me you don't mean to say he
has gone overboard
i asked i fear he has answered the
captain
this is the most extraordinary thing i
began
why he asked he is the fourth then
i explained in answer to another
question from the captain
i explained without mentioning the
doctor that i had heard the story
concerning 105.
he seemed very much annoyed at hearing
that i knew of it
i told him what had occurred in the
night what you say
he replied coincides almost exactly with
what was told me
by the roommates of two of the other
three they bolt out of bed and run down
the passage
two of them were seen to go overboard by
the watch
we stopped and lowered boats but they
were not found
nobody however saw or heard the man who
was lost last night
if he really is lost the steward who was
a superstitious fellow perhaps
and expected something to go wrong went
to look for him this morning
and found his birth empty but his
clothes lying about
just as he had left them the steward was
the only man on board who knew him by
sight
and he has been searching everywhere for
him he's disappeared
now sir i want to beg you not to mention
the circumstance to any of the
passengers
i don't want the ship to get a bad name
and nothing hangs about an ocean goer
like stories of suicides
you shall have your choice of any one of
the officers cabins you like
including my own for the rest of the
passage
is that a fair bargain very
said i and i am much obliged to you
but since i am alone and have the
stateroom to myself
i would rather not move if the steward
will take out that unfortunate man's
things
i would as leaf stay where i am i will
not say anything about the matter
and i think i can promise you that i
will not follow my roommate
the captain tried to dissuade me from my
intention
but i preferred having a stateroom alone
to being the chum of any officer on
board
i do not know whether i acted foolishly
but if i had taken his advice
i should have had nothing more to tell
there would have remained the
disagreeable coincidence of several
suicides
occurring among men who had slept in the
same cabin but that would have been all
that was not the end of the matter
however by any means
i obstinately made up my mind that i
would not be disturbed by such tales
and i even went so far as to argue the
question with the captain
there was something wrong about the
stateroom i said it was rather damp
the porthole had been left open last
night my roommate might have been ill
when he came on board
and he might have become delirious after
he went to bed
he might even now be hiding somewhere on
board and might be found later
the place ought to be aired and the
fastening of the port looked to
if the captain would give me leave i
would see that what i thought necessary
was done immediately
of course you have a right to stay where
you are if you please
he replied rather petulantly but i wish
you would turn out and let me lock the
place up
and be done with it i did not see it in
the same light
and left the captain after promising to
be silent concerning the disappearance
of my companion
the latter had had no acquaintances on
board and was not missed in the course
of the day
towards evening i met the doctor again
and he asked me whether i had changed my
mind
i told him i had not then you will
before long
he said very gravely
we played wist in the evening and i went
to bed late
i will confess now that i felt a
disagreeable sensation when i entered my
stateroom
i could not help thinking of the tall
man i had seen on the previous night
who was now dead drowned tossing about
in the long swell
two or three hundred miles a stern his
face rose very distinctly before me as i
undressed and i even went so far as to
draw back the curtains of the upper
birth
as though to persuade myself that he was
actually gone
i also bolted the door of the stateroom
[Music]
suddenly i became aware that the
porthole was open and fastened back
this was more than i could stand i
hastily threw on my dressing gown and
went in search of robert
the steward of my passage i was very
angry i remember
and when i found him i dragged him
roughly to the door of 105
and pushed him towards the open porthole
what the deuce do you mean you scoundrel
by leaving that port open every night
don't you know it's against the
regulations don't you know that if the
ship healed and the water began to come
in
ten men could not shut it i will report
you to the captain you blackguard for
endangering the ship
i was exceedingly roth the man trembled
and turned pale
and then began to shut the round glass
plate with the heavy brass fittings
why don't you answer me i said roughly
if you please sir faltered robert
there's nobody on board as can keep this
here porch shut at night
you can try it yourself sir i ain't
gonna stop any longer on board of this
vessel sir i ain't indeed
but if i was you sir i'd just clear out
and go and sleep with the surgeon or
something i would
look here sir is that fastened what you
may call securely
or not sir try it sir see if it will
move an inch
i tried the port and found it perfectly
tight
well sir continued robert triumphantly i
wager my
reputation as an a1 steward then at half
an hour it will be open again
fastened back too sir that's the awful
thing fasten back
i examined the great screw and the loop
nut that ran on it
if i find it open in the night robert i
will give you a sovereign
it is not possible you may go
sovereign did you say sir very good sir
thank you sir good night sir pleasant
repose sir
and all manner of enchanting dreams sir
roberts scuttled away delighted at being
released
of course i thought he was trying to
account for his negligence by a silly
story
intended to frighten me and i
disbelieved him
the consequence was that he got his
sovereign and i spent a very peculiarly
unpleasant night
i went to bed and five minutes after i
had rolled myself up in my blankets
the inexorable robert extinguished the
light that burned steadily behind the
ground glass
pane near the door i lay quite still in
the dark
trying to go to sleep but i soon found
that impossible
it had been some satisfaction to be
angry with the steward
and the diversion had banished that
unpleasant sensation
i had at first experienced when i
thought of the drowned man who had been
my chum
but i was no longer sleepy and i lay
awake for some time
occasionally glancing at the porthole
which i could just see from where i lay
and which in the darkness looked like a
faintly luminous soup plate suspended in
blackness
i believe i must have lained there for
an hour and as i remember
i was just dozing into sleep when i was
roused by a draft of cold air
and by distinctly feeling the spray of
the sea blown upon my face
i started to my feet and not having a
loud in the dark for the motion of the
ship
i was instantly thrown violently across
the state room
upon the couch which was placed beneath
the porthole
i recovered myself immediately however
and climbed upon my knees
the porthole was again wide open and
fastened back
now these things are facts i was wide
awake when i got up
and i should certainly have been awaked
by the fall had i still been dozing
moreover i bruised my elbows and knees
badly and the bruises were there in the
following morning
to testify to the fact if i myself had
doubted it
the porthole was wide open and fastened
back
a thing so unaccountable that i remember
very well feeling astonishment rather
than fear when i discovered it
i at once closed the plate again and
screwed down the loop nut with all my
strength
it was very dark in the state room i
reflected that the port had certainly
been opened within an hour after robert
had first shut it in my presence
and i determined to watch it and see
whether it would open again
those brass fittings are very heavy and
by no means easy to move
i could not believe that the clump had
been turned by the shaking of the screw
i stood peering out through the thick
glass at the alternate white and gray
streaks of the sea
that foamed beneath the ship's side i
must have remained there a quarter of an
hour
suddenly as i stood i distinctly heard
something moving behind me in one of the
births
and a moment afterward just as i turned
instinctively to look
though i could of course see nothing in
the darkness i heard a very faint groan
i sprang across the state room and tore
the curtains of the upper berth aside
thrusting in my hands to discover if
there were anyone there
there was someone i remember that the
sensation as i put my hands forward
was as though i were plunging them into
the air of a damp cellar
and from behind the curtains came a gust
of wind that smelled horribly of
stagnant seawater
i laid hold of something that had the
shape of a man's arm
but was smooth and wet and icy cold
but suddenly as i pulled the creature
sprang violently forward against me
a clammy oozy mass as it seemed to me
heavy and wet
yet endowed with a sort of supernatural
strength
i reeled across the state room and in an
instant the door
opened and the thing rushed out i had
not had time to be frightened
and quickly recovering myself i sprang
through the door and gave chase at the
top of my speed
but i was too late ten yards before me i
could see
i am sure i saw it a dark shadow moving
in the dimly lighted passage
quickly as the shadow of a fast horse
thrown before a dog
cart by the lamp on a dark night but in
a moment it had disappeared
and i found myself holding on to the
polished rail that ran along the
bulkhead where the passage turned
towards the companion
my hair stood on end and the cold
perspiration rolled down my face
i am not ashamed of it in the least i
was very badly frightened
still i doubted my senses and pulled
myself together
it was absurd i thought the welsh rare
bit i had eaten had disagreed with me
i'd been in a nightmare i made my way
back to my stateroom
and entered it with an effort the whole
place smelled of stagnant seawater
as it had when i had waked on the
previous evening
it required my utmost strength to go in
and grope among my things for a box of
wax lights
as i lighted a railway reading lantern
which i always carry
in case i want to read after the lamps
are out i perceived that the porthole
was again
open and a sort of creeping horror began
to take possession of me which i never
felt before
nor wished to feel again but i got a
light
and proceeded to examine the upper birth
expecting to find it drenched with
seawater
but i was disappointed the bed had been
slept in
and the smell of the sea was strong but
the bedding was as dry as a bone
i fancied that robert had not had the
courage to make the bed after the
accident of the previous night
it had all been a hideous dream i drew
the curtains back
as far as i could and examined the place
very carefully
it was perfectly dry but the porthole
was open again
with a sort of dull bewilderment of
horror i closed it and screwed it down
and thrusting my heavy stick through the
brass loop wrenched it with all my might
till the thick metal began to bend under
the pressure
then i hooked my reading lantern into
the red velvet at the head of the couch
and sat down to recover my senses if i
could
i sat there all night unable to think of
rest
hardly able to think at all but the
porthole remained closed
and i did not believe it would now open
again without the application of a
considerable force
the morning dawned at last and i dressed
myself slowly
thinking over all that it happened in
the night it was a beautiful day
and i went on deck glad to get out into
the early pure sunshine
and to smell the breeze from the blue
water so different from the noisome
stagnant odor of my stateroom
instinctively i turned aft towards the
surgeon's cabin
there he stood with a pipe in his mouth
taking his morning airing precisely as
on the preceding day
good morning said he quietly but looking
at me with evident curiosity
doctor you were quite right said i there
is something wrong about that place
i thought you would change your mind he
answered rather triumphantly
you've had a bad night eh shall i make
you a pick-me-up
i have a capital recipe no thanks i
cried
but i would like to tell you what
happened i then tried to explain as
clearly as possible
precisely what had occurred not
admitting to state that i had been
scared as i had never been scared in my
whole life before
i dwelt particularly on the phenomenon
of the porthole
which was a fact to which i could
testify even if the rest had been an
illusion
i had closed it twice in the night and
the second time i had actually bent the
brass in wrenching it with my stick
i believe i insisted a good deal on this
point
you seem to think i'm likely to doubt
the story said the doctor
smiling at the detailed account of the
state of the porthole
i do not doubt it in the least i renew
my invitation to you
bring your traps here and take half my
cabin come and take half of mine for one
night
i said help me get at the bottom of this
thing
you will get to the bottom of something
else if you try answered the doctor
what i asked the bottom of the sea i'm
going to leave this ship
it is not canny then you will not help
me to find out
not i said the doctor quickly it is my
business to keep my wits about me
not to go fiddling about with ghosts and
things
do you really believe it is a ghost i
inquired rather contemptuously
but as i spoke i remembered very well
the horrible sensation of the
supernatural which had got possession of
me during the night
the doctor turned sharply on me have you
any reasonable explanation of these
things to offer
he asked no you have not well
you say you will find an explanation i
say that you won't sir
simply because there is not any but my
dear
sir i retorted do you a man of science
mean to tell me that such things cannot
be explained
i do he answered stoutly and if they
could i would not be concerned in the
explanation
i did not care to spend another night
alone in the state room
and yet i was obstinately determined to
get at the root of the disturbances
i do not believe there are many men who
would have slept there alone
after passing two such nights but i made
up my mind to try it
if i could not get anyone to share a
watch with me the doctor was evidently
not inclined for such an experiment
he said he was a surgeon and that in
case any accident occurred on board he
must always be in readiness
he could not afford to have his nerves
unsettled
perhaps he was quite right but i am
inclined to think that his precaution
was prompted by his inclination
on inquiry he informed me that there was
no one on board who would be likely to
join me in my investigations
and after a little more conversation i
left him
a little later i met the captain and
told him my story
i said that if no one would spend the
night with me i would ask leave to have
the light burning all night and would
try it alone look here
said he i will tell you what i will do i
will share your watch myself
and we will see what happens it is my
belief that we can find out between us
there may be some fellow skulking on
board who steals a passage by
frightening the passengers
it is just possible that there may be
something queer in the carpentering of
that birth
i suggested taking the ship's carpenter
below and examining the place
but i was overjoyed at the captain's
offer to spend the night with me
he accordingly sent for the workmen and
ordered him to do anything i required
we went below at once i had all the
bedding cleared out of the upper berth
and we examined the place thoroughly to
see if there was a board loose anywhere
or a panel which could be opened or
pushed aside
we tried the planks everywhere tapped
the flooring
unscrewed the fittings of the lower
berth and took it to pieces
in short there was not a square inch of
the stateroom which was not searched and
tested
everything was in perfect order and we
put everything back in its place
as we were finishing our work robert
came to the door and looked in
well sir find anything sir he asked with
a ghastly
grin you were right about the porthole
robert
i said and i gave him the promised
sovereign the carpenter did his work
silently and skillfully following my
directions
when he had done he spoke i'm a plain
man sir
he said but it's my belief you had
better just turn out your things
and let me run half a dozen four inch
screws through the door of this cabin
there's no good never came of this cabin
yet sir and that's all about it
there's been four lives lost out of here
to my own remembrance
and that in four trips better give it up
sir
better give it up i will try it for one
night more
i said better give it up sir better give
it up
it's a precious bad job repeated the
workman putting his tools in his bag and
leaving the cabin
but my spirits had risen considerably at
the prospect of having the captain's
company
and i made up my mind not to be
prevented from going to the end of the
strange business
i abstained from welsh rare bits and
grog that evening
and did not even join in the customary
game of wist
i wanted to be quite sure of my nerves
and my vanity made me anxious to make a
good figure in the captain's eyes
the captain was one of those splendidly
tough and cheerful specimens of
seafaring humanity
whose combined courage hearty hood and
calmness and difficulty
leads them naturally into high positions
of trust he was not the man to be led
away by an idle tale
and the mere fact that he was willing to
join me in the investigation
was proof that he thought there was
something seriously wrong
which could not be accounted for on
ordinary theories
nor laughed down as a common
superstition
to some extent too his reputation was at
stake
as well as the reputation of the ship it
is no light thing to lose passengers
overboard
and he knew it about ten o'clock that
evening
as i was smoking a last cigar he came up
to me
and drew me aside from the beat of the
other passengers who were patrolling the
deck in the warm darkness
this is a serious matter mr brisbane he
said
we must make up our minds either way to
be disappointed or to have a pretty
rough time of it
you see i cannot afford to laugh at the
affair and i will ask you to sign your
name to a statement of whatever occurs
if nothing happens tonight we will try
it again tomorrow
and next day are you ready so we went
below and entered the stateroom
as we went in i could see robert the
steward who stood a little further down
the passage
watching us with his usual grin as
though certain that something dreadful
was about to happen
the captain closed the door behind us
and bolted it
supposing we put your portmanteau before
the door he suggested
one of us can sit on it nothing can get
out then
is the port screwed down i found it as i
had left it in the morning
indeed without using a lever as i had
done no one could have opened it
i drew back the curtains of the upper
berth so that i could see well into it
by the captain's advice i lighted my
reading lantern
and placed it so that it's shown upon
the white sheets above
he insisted upon sitting on the
portmanteau declaring that he wished to
be able to swear that he had sat before
the door
then he requested me to search the
stateroom thoroughly an operation very
soon accomplished
as it consisted merely in looking
beneath the lower berth and under the
couch below the porthole
the spaces were quite empty it is
impossible for any human being to get in
i said or for any human being to open
the port
very good said the captain calmly if we
see anything now it must be either
imagination or something supernatural
i sat down on the edge of the lower
berth
the first time it happened said the
captain crossing his legs and leaning
back against the door
was in march the passenger who slept
here
in the upper birth turned out to have
been a lunatic
at all events he was known to have been
a little touched and he had taken his
passage without the knowledge of his
friends
he rushed out in the middle of the night
and threw himself overboard
before the officer who had the watch
could stop him
we stopped and lowered a boat it was a
quiet night
just before that heavy weather came on
but we could not find him
of course his suicide was afterwards
accounted for on the ground of his
insanity i suppose that often happens
i remarked rather absently not often
no said the captain never before in my
experience though i have heard of it
happening on board of other ships
well as i was saying that occurred in
march on the very next trip
what are you looking at he asked
stopping suddenly in his narration
i believe i gave no answer my eyes were
riveted upon the porthole
it seemed to me that the brass loop nut
was beginning to turn
very slowly upon the screw so slowly
however
that i was not sure it moved at all i
watched it intently
fixing its position in my mind and
trying to ascertain whether it changed
seeing where i was looking the captain
looked too
it moves he exclaimed in a tone of
conviction
no it does not he added after a minute
if it were the jarring of the screw said
i it would have opened during the day
but i found it this evening jammed tight
as i left it this morning
i rose and tried the nut it was
certainly loosened
for by an effort i could move it with my
hands
the queer thing said the captain is that
the second man who was lost is supposed
to have got through that very port
we had a terrible time over it it was in
the middle of the night
and the weather was very heavy there was
an alarm that one of the ports was open
and the sea running in i came below and
found everything flooded
the water pouring in every time she
rolled and the whole port swinging from
the top bolts
not the porthole in the middle well we
managed to shut it but the water did
some damage
ever since that the place smells of sea
water from time to time
we suppose the passenger had thrown
himself out though the lord only knows
how he did it
the steward kept telling me that he
cannot keep anything shut here
upon my word i can smell it now can't
you
he inquired sniffing the air
suspiciously
yes distinctly i said and i shuddered as
that same odor of stagnant seawater grew
stronger in the cabin
now to smell like this the place must be
damp i continued
and yet when i examined it with a
carpenter this morning everything was
perfectly dry
it is most extraordinary hello
my reading lantern which had been placed
in the upper birth was suddenly
extinguished
there was still a good deal of light
from the pane of ground glass near the
door
behind which loomed the regulation lamp
the ship rolled heavily
and the curtain of the upper berth swung
far out into the state room and back
again
i rose quickly from my seat on the edge
of the bed and the captain at the same
moment started to his feet with a loud
cry of surprise
i had turned with the intention of
taking down the lantern to examine it
when i heard his exclamation and
immediately afterwards his call for help
i sprang towards him he was wrestling
with all his might with the brass loop
of the port
it seemed to turn against his hands in
spite of all his efforts
i caught up my cane a heavy oak stick i
always used to carry
and thrust it through the ring and bore
on it with all my strength
but the strong wood snapped suddenly and
i fell upon the couch
when i rose again the port was wide open
and the captain was standing with his
back against the door
pale to the lips there's something in
that birth
he cried in a strange voice his eyes
almost starting from his head
hold the door while i look it shall not
escape us whatever it is
but instead of taking his place i sprang
upon the lower bed
and sees something which lay in the
upper birth
it was something ghostly horrible beyond
words and it moved in my grip
it was like the body of a man long
drowned and yet it moved
and had the strength of ten men living
but i gripped it with all my might
the slippery oozy horrible thing the
dead white eyes seemed to stare at me
out of the dusk
the putrid odor of rank seawater was
about it and its shiny hair hung in foul
wet curls over its dead face
i wrestled with the dead thing it thrust
itself upon me and forced me back and
nearly broke my arms
it wound its corpse's arms about my neck
the living death and overpowered me
so that i at last cried aloud and fell
and left my hold
as i fell the thing sprang across me and
seemed to throw itself upon the captain
when i last saw him on his feet his face
was white and his lips set
it seemed to me that he struck a violent
blow with the dead being and then he
too fell forward upon his face with an
inarticulate cry of horror
the thing paused an instant seeming to
hover over his prostrate body
and i could have screamed again for very
fright but i had no voice left
the thing vanished suddenly and it
seemed to my disturbed senses that it
made its exit through the open port
though how that was possible considering
the smallness of the aperture is more
than anyone can tell
i lay a long time upon the floor and the
captain lay beside me
at last i partially recovered my senses
and moved
and instantly i knew that my arm was
broken the small bone of the left
forearm near the wrist
i got upon my feet somehow and with my
remaining hand i tried to raise the
captain
he groaned and moved and at last came to
himself
he was not hurt but he seemed badly
stunned
well do you want to hear any more there
is nothing more
that is the end of my story the
carpenter carried out his scheme of
running half a dozen 4-inch screws
through the door of 105.
and if ever you take a passage in the
kamchatka you may ask for a birth in
that stateroom
you will be told that it is engaged yes
it is engaged by that dead thing
i finished the trip in the surgeon's
cabin he doctored my broken arm
and advised me not to fiddle about with
ghosts and things anymore
the captain was very silent and never
sailed again in that ship
though it is still running and i will
not sail in her either
it was a very disagreeable experience
and i was very badly frightened which is
a thing i do not like
that is all that is how i saw a ghost
if it was a ghost it was dead anyhow
you